نعلم أن دواء أيدن وصل
الليلة الماضية لكن هل وصل أه
الفلسطينيين والرهائن الإسرائيليين
بعد هل
تعلم من الجيد أن أتحدث إليكم مرة أخرى بيكي
المعلومات التي لدينا الآن هي
أنه تم نقل الدواء
والمساعدات حوالي 11 طن طن  أه أدوية
وإمدادات طبية
ومساعدات إنسانية أه تم نقلها إلى
غزة عن طريق المركز الأحمر المصري
واستلمتها غزة
وزارة الصحة الفلسطينية
هناك مازلنا ليس لدينا تأكيد
على ذلك كما قلت هناك
انقطاع في الاتصالات في الدقة الأمر صعب للغاية
للحصول على أي معلومات مباشرة من
هناك، ولكننا سعداء الآن على الأقل
بوجود 11 طنًا من المساعدات الطبية التي
لم تكن موجودة لولا ذلك، كما تعلم أن
جميع المستشفيات الموجودة خارج الخدمة،
فهي خارج الخدمة تمامًا من أي نوع من
المساعدات الطبية  باستثناء ذلك الذي يأتي
عبر الجانب الإنساني
وخاصة عندما يتعلق الأمر بالرهائن،
فبعضهم لديه بعض الحالات المزمنة كما
قلت، وباعتباري مريضًا بالسكري،
لا أستطيع أن أتخيل
العيش يومًا بدون دوائي،
وبالتالي من الجيد أن نفعل ذلك  الخطوة
الآن وآمل أن يؤدي ذلك إلى
مزيد من الخطوات في
المستقبل. أفهم أنك تقول
إن الاتصالات صعبة للغاية
ولكن دعني أضغط عليك فيما يتعلق
بالصفقة، أعني متى كان من
المتوقع أن يصل هذا الدواء إلى
الأفراد  وبالضبط كيف سيتم
تسهيل ذلك ماجد على
الأغلب أنه من الممكن أن يكون قد
وصل بالفعل إلى أه الرهائن ونحن
نعلم أنه كما أخبرتك فإن منصات
الأدوية والأطقم الطبية التي
دخلت بالفعل أصبحت في
أيدي مسؤولي وزارة الصحة
هناك، لذا فإن الأمر يتعلق
بإيصالها إلى الأشخاص المحتاجين، ومن
المرجح أن تكون قد وصلت بالفعل
ولكن ليس لدينا أي تأكيد
على ذلك وسأبقيك على علم
بالفكرة بالتأكيد  كان على
مسؤولي وزارة الصحة نقل أه
الدواء إلى المحتاجين
مباشرة وقد تم الاتفاق بين
الجانبين على معايير صارمة للغاية
بين بالطبع هو
وحماس لذلك اسمحوا لي أن أوضح هذا تمامًا
أن الصليب الأحمر ليس كذلك  متورط بشكل مباشر
وإذا لم يكن الأمر
كذلك فلماذا لا يكون الهلال الأحمر من
الجانب المصري المعادل
للصليب الأحمر في مصر أه
مكلفا بإيصال الدواء
إلى الحدود كما تعلمون الوضع
داخل ر متقلب للغاية هناك
انقطاع تام للاتصالات كما قلت
لكن
الوضع الأمني ​​بالتأكيد ليس سهلاً
سيكون من الصعب جدًا إشراك أه
أشخاص من الصليب الأحمر أو أي
منظمة أخرى في الوقت الحالي
الأشخاص القديرين في وزارة الصحة في إلزا الذين
يعملون  ليلا ونهارا هناك
بالطبع تم تكليفنا
بتسليم الدواء الذي
نعمل به كما هو واضح
وفي سيناريوهات أفضل كنا سنرى
طرقًا أفضل لتوصيل الدواء
والتأكد من أنه كريس ولكن
هذا هو  الوضع الذي لدينا ونحن
نعمل بالطبع تحت ضغط الوقت،
أعتقد أنه من المهم بالنسبة لنا أن نكون
واضحين جدًا بشأن هذا الأمر بشأن ما هو كاتا أو
نوع الضمانات التي يتم
تقديمها أو التي يمكن أن تقدمها كاتا بشأن وصول الدواء
والمساعدات فعليًا إلى الإسرائيليين
الرهائن بل والمدنيين الفلسطينيين
المدنيين في غزة لأن إسرائيل
من جانبها بالطبع تقول وأقتبس
هنا أنها لا تملك القدرة على
ضمان وصول الدواء إلى
الرهائن الإسرائيليين في غزة ماذا
تستفيد من
ذلك جيداً كما تعلم بيكي أنا  آسف في كل
مرة أتواصل معك يجب أن أعطي
نفس الإجابة لكنك تعلم
حساسيات المحادثات حيث
لا يمكننا نشر جميع المعلومات
المتعلقة بأه خصوصيات
الاتفاقيات ما يمكنني قوله لك هو أن
كلا الجانبين  أه كنا سعداء
بالاتفاق كما هو وكان هناك
إيمان من الطرفين بأن الاتفاق
سيؤدي إلى ما اتفقنا عليه وهو
وصول الدواء إلى أه المحتاجين
من الرهائن والمدنيين
نحن واثقون من أن هذا كان  تم ذلك
بحسن نية من قبل الجانبين،
ونأمل أن يؤدي ذلك إلى شيء
ملموس أكثر في المستقبل